mornings are about to improve for the
Italian astronaut who's been suffering
through instant coffee at the
International Space Station an espresso
machine is on the spacex supply capsule
that was scheduled for launch earlier
this week especially designed Italian
made espresso maker is intended for
astronaut samantha cristoforetti who
arrived on the space station in November
all right so I had to do this story
obviously because it combines two of my
favorite things space and coffee if you
were going up to space what would be
like the one thing that you absolutely
cuz I would need the coffee I related to
that so much as like if I were up there
that'd be the one thing I would ask for
I'll send me espresso yes absolutely you
don't drink coffee you don't smoke weed
told you Badshah like I don't really
understand you should be bottling that
[ __ ]
I will patent-pending guys yeah but if
you were going up to space well be a man
okay sorry I should have thought that
not setting no no did man I've had it
happen once not again all right a live
man that seems that seems probably
doable when you guys doable literally oh
my god will you guys go to space if you
could I love it I love the idea that
even these people that are doing this
Mars thing where it's only gonna be a
one-way trip and they know they're not
coming home like to me like I can't I
get nauseous on a frickin
merry-go-around so I'm not going to
space anytime soon space is so cool and
I would love to see it maybe it just
scares me like honestly I haven't even
been on a cruise because I'm afraid of
going on a boat out into the middle of
an ocean and just feeling like you know
there's no safety I don't know scariest
part of this cruise no the scariest part
of a cruise is the all-you-can-eat
buffet that's yeah I mean these people
have you seen these people at the buffet
it's scary I wouldn't worry about the
water I'm just I just I guess you feel
scared no I've seen yeah I've seen a lot
of space movies to us on revenue okay so
I don't think so no space space would
you go you don't want to go to space
gravity I really liked it yeah enough to
have learned from her mistake don't go
don't go to stuff
yeah what so with the boats though why
are we searching that way you know James
Cameron he's building all this crazy
technology to go further below the water
than we ever have and I guess the next
couple avatars are gonna be underwater
but we have so much to explore that's on
this little blue dot it's floating
around like maybe we're not to go out
there maybe we just need to go down
there we pretty much sucked we're
sucking everything out of this one
they're like let's look for a new planet
so that in a hundred years when this
one's toast yeah we can move you think
it's gonna be a hundred years I'm
looking at like 40 I was being
optimistic I told you I'm smiley
yeah we're exploring down there why
don't we do more of that like I feel
like that's just like if you were if an
explorer was like yes I'm gonna go down
to the depths of the Pacific people
would be like come on dude this is in
1920 I don't think it'd be cool I mean
anything that's unknown should be
explored